these are not necessarily places I'm
going to recommend but if you find
yourself there you got to eat today
we've taken a look at five Mexican fast
food restaurants and we're trying to
find the healthiest options for you if
these are the places you find yourself
at first up we're looking at Taco Bell
one of the things I liked about Taco
Bell is that they're up front with their
ingredient and I saw they have like a
healthy menu and I had those go for them
so I did the cantina powerbal I don't
care for cheese so I take off the cheese
but I'm going to add in there their
salsa but not the regular salsa the
salsa that has a pic of de gallo because
it has less sodium in it I did not do
the guacamole wasn't worth it I'd rather
just eat an avocado later so next up we
have del Taco I don't really have
anything I would get a Del Taco so if
you're gonna go to Del Taco this is what
I would say get get what you want it's
hanging me that good for you totally I
always think you're so healthy I was
shocked at the amount of fat we're
talking two days worth of fat don't even
go into the tacos or the burritos just
don't even I would get the burrito bowl
black beans or rice I would get the
chicken and I would get pico de gallo
with it and I would get the fajita
veggies no teeth no guacamole sorry to
say I was surprised it actually had some
really good options the one that I would
get is the classical salad you can get
it with or without chicken it doesn't
change it too much in terms of fat I
wouldn't get it with a cheese but no if
you do get it with the cheese it brings
up the fat the saturated fat in
particular and then I would actually get
the dressing on the side and avocado
salsa I I've eaten at Baja Fresh
I liken the sound of the names fresh I
think they're gonna have fresh
ingredients there I I was surprised at
how many calories are in some of the
salads so the one that I picked was the
Baja barbecue chicken salad
I put the dressing on it and even with
the dressing it's not too bad in terms
of
calories if they offer fresh avocado I
would put that on there but I wouldn't
do the guacamole the biggest surprise
for me with Baja was that all their
tostada salads are over a thousand
calories if I'm going to eat a thousand
calories for a salad I'm going all-out
for a burrito that has the works with
all kinds of sour cream and guacamole
and I'm just going to forget so here are
my top three ways that you can eat
healthier first number one don't order
off the menu so have an idea of what you
want before you go in and then try to
add some healthy things to it so number
two is have your sauces and your
dressings on the side get it on the side
put a little bit on or dip your fork in
or dip your food in and just eat a
little bit of it that will say powers
and number three is whenever you can add
vegetables go for it that's going to
bulk things up it's going to give you
more fiber more vitamins and minerals
and you won't have to eat as many of the
tacos of the burritos or the other
options because you'll be more full on
roughage